Where I come from
societies are quite divided.
There are visible walls
protecting against supposed dangers,
walls marking limits of properties, marking
borders,
or separating ethnic or religious groups.
But there are also invisible walls:
the ones in the minds of people.
I grew up in Peru, Mexico, Bolivia,
Germany and the former-Yugoslavia.
And if nothing else they all had
that one thing in common.
I have always wondered what kind of stories
I can find on both sides of the wall.
This is why I became a journalist.
Walls are borders based on fears and clichés.
But as it turns out, the stories on both sides
are often very similar.
With fake news running rampant,
it’s more important than ever to go out
and talk to people.
To understand their point of view.
To keep on being interested and curious
on both sides of the wall,
because the truth is never going to be only
on one side.